JESSE WATTERS, AND GREG GUTFELD.
THIS IS A "THE FIVE"
THIS IS A "THE FIVE."
PRESIDENT TRUMP LIGHTING UP THE
WORLD'S STAGE OF IMPEACHMENT
ENTERING A NEW PHASE.
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
EXPECTED TO VOTE SOON ON
CHAIRMAN ADAM SCHIFF'S NEW
RELEASED REPORT.
THE G.O.P. RELEASED THEIR
PRERATTLE REPORT SAYING THERE'S
NO EVIDENCE OF AN IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSE AND WARNED THAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE SETTING A
DANGEROUS PRECEDENT.
TRUMPS ON AND OFF ON ALL THIS
WHILE HE ATTENDED THE NATO
SUMMIT IN LONDON.
>> I THINK IT'S VERY UNPATRIOTIC
OF THE DEMOCRATS TO PUT ON A
PERFORMANCE WHERE THEY DID THAT.
I DO.
I THINK IT'S A BAD THING FOR OUR
COUNTRY.
IMPEACHMENT WASN'T SUPPOSED TO
BE USED THAT WAY.
I THINK IT'S A DISGRACE.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS SHOULD BE
ENSLAVED AND OF THEMSELVES.
DEMO THE MICRO REPUBLICANS HAVE
NEVER BEEN STRONGER, NEVER MORE
UNIFIED, THE DEMOCRATS HAVE GONE
CRAZY.
HIS PEACOAT PRESIDENT SAVING
MORE HARSH WORDS FOR SPEAKER
NANCY PELOSI AND CHAIRMAN
ADAM SCHIFF.
>> ADAM SCHIFF IS A DERANGED
HUMAN BEING.
I THINK HE GREW UP WITH A
COMPLEX AND A LOT OF REASONS
THAT ARE OBVIOUS.
I THINK IS A VERY SICK MAN AND
HE LIES.
ADAM SCHIFF MADE UP MY
CONVERSATION WITH THE PRESIDENT
OF UKRAINE.
NANCY PELOSI KNEW HE WAS LYING
AND SHE WENT ON HER SHOW AND SHE
SAID HE TOLD THE TRUTH SO SHE
WAS LYING TOO.
THESE PEOPLE ARE DERANGED.
>> Dana: THE PRESIDENT OVER
THERE IN THE U.K. TRYING TO DO
SOME BUSINESS BUDDIES GOT TO
DEAL WITH POLITICS BACK HOME.
>> Greg: THE QUESTION IS, IS
THIS UNPATRIOTIC?
I WAS THINKING ABOUT THAT.
IS IT UNPATRIOTIC TO UNDO AN
ELECTION IN A PROCESS THAT
STARTED THE DAY AFTER THE
ELECTION?
I WOULD SAY THAT'S UNPATRIOTIC.
TRYING TO CANCEL THE VOTES OF
HALF OF THE COUNTRY TO SOOTHE
YOUR EMOTIONAL DAMAGE BECAUSE
DADDY HURTS YOU, THAT'S
UNPATRIOTIC.
IT SAYS A LOT ABOUT YOUR
EMOTIONAL FAITH.
A PROCEEDING WITH THE CIRCUS
KNOWING THAT THERE IS A SPLIT IN
THE COUNTRY, THAT HALF THE
COUNTRY IS AGAINST IT, THAT IS
UNTRUE UNPATRIOTIC GREAT AS YOU
KNOW, GO TO CREATE
WIDESPREAD DISCONTENT AND
PERHAPS ECONOMIC COLLAPSE?
I WOULD SAY THAT'S UNPATRIOTIC.
SO YOU ARE PURSUING ALL OF THIS
RATHER THAN PARTICIPATING IN AN
ELECTION THAT YOU START THIS
PROCESS THREE YEARS AGO AND IT'S
ALL BECAUSE YOU FEEL BAD INSIDE.
YOU ARE PUTTING YOUR FEELINGS
ARE FOR.
UNPATRIOTIC.
>> Dana: ADAM SCHIFF, JUAN
SAYS IN HIS REPORT THAT
PARTICULARLY SPENT A LOT OF TIME
PARTICULARLY SPENT A LOT OF TIMI
PARTICULARLY SPENT A LOT OF TIMN
REPORT TALKING ABOUT THE RESIDEN
REPORT TALKING ABOUT THE RESIDET
OBSTRUCTING THE PROCESS.
>> Juan: FROM THE DEMOCRATS
PERSPECTIVE, THEY ARE MORE
INTERESTED IN 2020 THEN THEY ARE
IN 2016.
WHAT THEY SAY IS THIS PRESIDENT
WAS A LISTING FOR NATIONS
INTERFERING IN THE UPCOMING
ELECTION SO TO ME IT'S LIKE YOU
HAVE TWO REPORTS, ONE FROM THE
REPUBLICANS, ONE FROM THE
DEMOCRATS, AND IT'S LIKE
ULTIMATE REALITY.
IT'S LIKE LISTENING TO ME AND
GREG ON THE SHOW AND YOU HAVE
THE G.O.P. SAYING THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH EVIDENCE HERE FOR
IMPEACHMENT.
WHERE IS THE HARD EVIDENCE?
WHERE ARE THE DIRECT TESTIMONIES
FROM ANYBODY ABOUT A QUID PRO
QUO BRIBERY WHATEVER?
I'M IN THE YOU HAVE THE
DEMOCRATS COME OUT AND THEY SAY
THIS UNBELIEVABLE
UNPRECEDENTED OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE AND OBSTRUCTION OF AN
IMPEACHMENT PROCESS TELLING
PEOPLE NOT TO COME TESTIFY
BEFORE AN EQUAL BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT OF CONGRESS, KEEPING
DOCUMENTS AWAY FROM CONGRESS,
AND WE HAVE A CALL LOG, AND THAT
WAS THE ONE THING THAT REALLY
STRUCK ME.
THE REPUBLICANS ARE REALLY ALL
ABOUT THE POLITICAL ARGUMENT,
THE DEMOCRATS OFFER SOME FACTUAL
BASIS SAYING HERE ARE CALL LOGS
THAT DEMONSTRATE HOW
DEVIN NUNES, WHO IS THE LEAD
REPUBLICAN ON HOUSE INTEL, WAS
INVOLVED WITH RUDY GIULIANI, THE
PRESIDENT'S LAWYER, WITH THE
PRESIDENT, WITH THIS GUY HAS
BEEN INDICTED FOR FINANCIAL
CAMPAIGN ABUSE --
>> Dana: THEY HAVE A CALL LOGS
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE WHAT THEY
SAID IN THE CALL LOGS.
>> Juan: IT SURE LOOKS BAD.
HE SPEAKS TO MIKE >> Katie: I
THINK IT'S INTERESTING THAT
ADAM SCHIFF IS LOOKING AT PHONE
CALLS MAKE IT A
MIC MADE BY THE RANKING MEMBER
TO COME TO SOME KIND OF AGREEMEN
TO COME TO SOME KIND OF AGREEMET
ABOUT HOW THEY CAN MOVE FORWARD.
IT'S OBVIOUS FROM THAT THAT THEY
CERTAINLY WON'T BE GETTING ALONG
IN THE FUTURE.
IF IT IS INTERESTING HOW
ADAM SCHIFF CLAIMED THAT HE HAS
ALL OF THIS INFORMATION MOVING
FORWARD AND IT'S URGENT THAT
THEY GET IT TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND THEY CONTINUE TO
INVESTIGATE EVEN AFTER IT HANDED
OVER WHILE ALSO ADMITTING THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE ALL OF THE
INFORMATION, THAT THEY HAVE AN
KEY PEOPLE THAT WERE NAMED IN
THIS TESTIMONY WHO HAVEN'T
SPOKEN TO HIM AND IT'S VERY
CLEAR THAT SCHIFF DOESN'T
HAVE THE CONFIDENCE TO GO
THROUGH THE COURT SYSTEMS TRY TO
FIND OUT IF HE HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO HOLD PEOPLE LIKE
SECRETARY POMPEO --
>> Dana: ABOUT GOING TO COURT.
JESSIE, I'M SURE YOU HAVE A LOT
OF THOUGHTS ON THIS.
>> Jesse: WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
IMPEACHING THE PRESIDENT AND
WANTED TALKING ABOUT CALL LOGS.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
WE WERE PROMISED HIGH CRIMES AND
MISDEMEANORS AND HE'S TALKING
ABOUT A CALL LOG.
COME ON, JUAN.
NO ONE IS TALKING ABOUT UKRAINE
FOR THE WHOLE THING BACKFIRED WE
LOOK AT EVERY SINGLE SWING
STATE, IMPEACHMENT IS NOW UNDER
WATER.
THIS UNIFIED REPUBLICANS MORE
THAN IT UNIFIED DEMOCRATS.
DEMOCRATS ARE BROKE.
THE DNC HAS NO MONEY,
REPUBLICANS ARE RAISING MONEY
LIKE I'M NOT GOING TO SAY IT.
THEY ARE RAISING A LOT OF MONEY
AND NOW THEY ARE TRYING TO PLAY
ALL OF THESE TRICKS LIKE THEY
DID WITH CAVANAUGH AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN AMBASSADOR SONDLAND GETS
HIT WITH NOT ONE, NOT TO COME
ABOUT THREE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
ALLEGATIONS IN THE MIDDLE OF ALL
THIS?
AND OVER THERE, MILANI IS
LOOKING VERY STRIKING, FRESH OFF
KILLING BAGHDADI AND UNIFYING
NATO AGAINST THE RUSSIANS THE
MENU HAS ADAM SCHIFF PASSING
THIS LITTLE SCAM TO JERRY NADLER
WHO IS SUPPOSED TO CARRY IT
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE?
I DON'T SEE HOW THIS IS GOING TO
STICK AND EVEN THE SWING STATE
DEMOCRATS KNOW IT BECAUSE THEY
ARE WHISPERING ABOUT WAYS TO GET
OUT OF HAVING A VOTE FOR THIS
NOW.
>> Dana: NOW THE DEMOCRATS ARE
KIND OF IN THE STOCKS WERE IF
THEY DON'T GO FORWARD, THEY ARE
BASICALLY GOING TO BE FURIOUS,
BUT IF THEY DO GO FORWARD,
THEY COULD PAY THE PRICE AT THE
BALLOT BOX.
>> Greg: I THINK WE PREDICTED
THIS BID WE SAW IT COMING GOOD
I, FOR ONE, HOPE THEY CONTINUE
WITH THIS BECAUSE IT'S SOMETHING
TO TALK ABOUT ON "THE FIVE"
DURING THE SLOW DAYS BUT I DO FE
DURING THE SLOW DAYS BUT I DO FL
THAT I REFUSE TO BE LED BY THE
NOSE BY SHIFT WITH THESE FAKE
LITTLE INQUIRY REPORTS AND
WERE NOT CREATED TO YOUR POINT,
IT'S ALL MUCH ADO ABOUT NOTHING.
SOMETHING I THINK I COINED.
I CAME UP WITH THAT.
EVERYTHING HE DOES IS ON
BEHALF --
HE IS LIKE OUR AGENT.
HE'S AMERICA'S AGENT IN A
MEETING AND HE IS SUCH A JERK
BUT HE'S OUR JERK.
DID YOU SEE HOW HE DEALT WITH
THE CANADIAN --
HE TREATED THEM AS THOUGH HE WAS
THE MANAGER OF A GOLF COURSE
OWNED BY TRUMP.
CAN YOU TELL US WHAT WE WORK OUT
HERE, WHAT IS THAT YOU OWE US,
AND HE MADE --
WHAT'S HIS NAME AGAIN?
TRUDEAU.
IT'S LIKE GOING LIKE LET ME GO
THROUGH --
AND HE IS LIKE BASICALLY SAYING
YES, SIR.
IT WAS LIKE THE
"CELEBRITY APPRENTICE."
IT WAS INTERESTING TO SEE THAT
EVERYTHING HE DOES IS ON BEHALF
OF AMERICA.
HE IS LIKE THAT COMFORTABLE
PERSON WHO GOES UP TO SOMEBODY
AND SAYS YOU OWE US MONEY.
>> Juan: THE OTHER SIDE IS
BASIS TO WATCH HIM DEAL WITH THE
FRENCH PRIME MINISTER WHERE YOU
SAW --
TO ME, IT WAS LIKE HE WAS
LECTURING TRUMP.
I THOUGHT TRUMP IN THAT EXCHANGE
LOOKED LIKE YOU THINK THAT THIS
IS ABOUT TERRORISM?
NO, I THINK IT'S ABOUT NOT BEING
FAIR BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T PAY ME
THE MONEY, ACTUALLY YOU GUYS --
WE ARE GETTING OTHER PEOPLE AND
WE ARE DOING SO MUCH BETTER AND
NATO WAS GOING TO FOLD AND NOW
HE IS YEAH BUT --
WHAT IS NATO FOR?
IS IT FOR TERRACE OR THE
RUSSIANS AND THE PRESIDENT COULD
NOT AGREE.
BEFORE I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN QUITE CRITICAL OF NATO AND
THEN PRESIDENT McCONE WAS
CRITICAL OF NATO AND CALLED A